game time the pods are now open love is
blind contestants came on the show
hoping to find love in the pods but
turns out two of the cast members
already had a connection yeah you heard
me get this kelly chase and Jessica
batten have actually known each other
for a decade okay so not a love
connection but still crazy right here's
what went down during a recent Instagram
Q&A with fans both jess and kelly
confirmed that they were longtime gal
pals before shooting the show who else
is shook anyway moving it along when one
fan asked Jessica if she knew Kelly
ahead of filming the hit Netflix dating
show she shared this throwback pic of
them writing I've known Kel for 10 years
then when another fan asked Kelly how
they knew each other she explained that
they met through an ex-boyfriends same
social circle their friendship was never
addressed on the show but they did have
a few heart-to-hearts about their
potential future hubby's I make a lie
about how I feel I want to like not
leave today god I love this show anyway
both Jessica and Kelly got engaged on
the show I want to ask you will you
marry me
[Music]
yes I want to ask you Kelly Marie will
you marry me I will but they both said I
don't at the altar I cannot I don't
Lord that was brutal it still makes me
uncomfortable
justice for Marc right anyway he caught
up with Jessica and Kelly during the
love is blind reunion taping there was
one experience of kind of living it and
then there's the secondary experience of
watching it back they shared what it was
like to relive all that craziness again
on TV it's a very surreal experience
Amanda as you could see I got a little
emotional not emotional so and it was
like even watching the series back
myself I it was a nostalgic kind of like
wow that like it brought up the feelings
of what was happening in that current
time but like to really even more of the
emotional side of like wow I have like
really evolved so much since then so it
wasn't like a sad cry it was more of
like a I'm proud of you it's been a
struggle to watch it back because I saw
I was really working through some things
that I needed to deal with and so you
know as hard as it was though it's it is
kind of therapeutic on the other side to
know that I was able to work through
some of those things again that wasn't
the initial objective of coming on to
the show but you know I think I'm better
for it so what's next for these ladies I
feel like I'm having a fresh start and I
feel really good about where I'm at and
you know finally starting to open myself
up again but wouldn't be able to do that
without the lessons that I learned here
and you know from where I am single but
yes I am looking to date I would do the
show again yeah Jessica and Kelly first
season two of love is blind
what's going on
hell yes I am in like ten out of ten in
Jessica you make good TV girl different
decades like you name it like we're
different and why do things why did you
say yes
and if not hey ABC get these gals on The
Bachelor of course stick with ET for all
things love is blind until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens and I'll see you soon
[Music]